des images insoutenables des hommes
assassinés brûlés vifs que nous avons
choisi de flouter cette scène d'une
extrême violence a lieu cette semaine à
l'entrée sud de la capitale port au
prince
nous sommes à martissant une zone de non
droit où des gangs lourdement armés
sèment la terreur sous fond de crise
sociale et politique
alors pour mieux comprendre cette montée
de violence nous sommes rapprochés de
radio magik 9 roberson alphonse ici à
l'antenne nous explique pourquoi
officiellement la volée ce paul de trois
morts ils ne sont pas positionnés là
parce que cette stratégie qu'ils sont là
parce qu'ils vivent dans ces quartiers
précaires se trouve au pied de mon
hôpital ils vivent dans la précarité ce
sont des jeunes pour beaucoup un échec
scolaire en effet crucial ce sont pour
beaucoup aussi des jeunes qui végète de
la pauvreté qui n'ont pas suffisamment
de moigné ou résister aux sollicitations
de certains cadres politiques dans
certains cas du temps de
deux personnalités du secteur privé pour
qu'il s'investit dans des activités
criminelles
un artiste en ici comme vous pouvez le
constater c'est la salubrité la pauvreté
qui règne
deux indicateurs majeurs qui génère de
la violence des violences où s'expriment
au rythme des tensions politiques comme
si elle a lui souligné certains
observateurs du pays